[Music]  Magnus haha maybe you'll be the  Terminator someone actually called them  Sarang  that's kind of the things that stuck in  my head so probably King Kong I think is  his hog Magnus maybe James Bond here  just a cool guy especially now he could  use his care care card you know he's  probably you know putting some Gail over  his head you know I mean just like a  dingo Harry Potter I'll say Harry Potter  for Magnus he's very talented very  bright and that's magic  okay thank  [Music]  I don't I haven't no reason for that I'm  you know idea okay but he's pretty evil  dude I probably want to be a villain  that seems more more interesting in  general pain  [Music]